hey everyone in stairs read sterner
sorry and calm and in this video I want
to show you how to administer I draw so
the first thing what you want to do is
you want to perform hand hygiene and you
want to wash your hands so we're going
to do that real fast use some hand
sanitizer and we're going to dawn and
glove and after we do that we are going
to first assess the eye and what we're
looking for we're looking for any
excessive redness or drainage and a lot
of times patients and they may be
getting eye drops because they have an
eye infection and if you're giving it
sometimes usually in the morning that I
may be matted up and close or have x-u
day around it so what you want to do is
you want to clean it so to remove any
excessive drainage or crust you're going
to take a washcloth with warm water and
you're gently going to start at the
inner part of the eye and you're going
to work your way out we're just gently
removing it and then you're going to
change your gloves and wash your hands
and put a new pair of gloves on now
after you've wiped the eye what you want
to do is you want to do the patient's
rights you want to make sure you have
the right patient the right medication
the right dose the right route and the
right time and when you're administering
eyedrops you want to make sure that you
really pay attention to which I draw go
in which I because sometimes patients
have more than one type of eye drops are
using and how many drops goes in each
eyes so be aware of that then you need
to position your patient so what you
want to do is you want to have your
patient tilt their head back and look at
the ceiling now if your patient cannot
do this or in the bed and what you can
do is you can lay the bed back a little
bit and reposition their head with a
pillow to help assist them and being
able to get in this position because we
want to do this so whenever we instill
the drops they don't easily leak out and
they can go really easy into that
conjunctival
back now you're going to take your
non-dominant hand and you can use in
either your thumb or your finger and get
a piece of tissue paper to collect any
excessive drainage and you're going to
rest that on the cheekbone and what
you're going to do is you're going to
didn't Lee pull down on that lower lid
to expose the conjunctival sack because
this is where we will spill the drop
we're not going to instill the drops on
the eyeball over the cornea because that
is a sensitive area but in this facts
right here at the lower lid see you're
going to take your dominant hand and
just rest it a little bit above the
eyebrow and you're going to take the eye
drops put them in between your thumb and
your index finger and gently tilt them
over and we're going to instill in the
conjunctival sight the prescribed amount
of drops and you want to be careful not
to get this kit in the eye and
contaminate the tip of it so we're going
to instill the two drop okay then the
patient's going to close their eyes and
tell them to roll their eyeball around
to coat the eye with the medication and
dab the eye with the tissue paper to
collect any excessive drainage now
sometimes after you administer eyedrops
you may have to perform tonsil occlusion
and this is usually done whenever you're
administering a medication where a
patient who has glaucoma and it's used
for medications like the beta blockers a
popular one like Timmel or any of your
medications they ended Oh lol or alpha
at energic agonist and to do this you
will take the finger and you will put it
to the bridge of the nose over the
pumpkin and hold it firmly but gently to
block the solution from going down into
the nasolacrimal duct because if that
happens the medication we want to stay
in the eye we don't want to go down
through the throat and enter into the
systemic circulation because one under
patient isn't getting the full dose in
the eye and second it can cause signs
and symptoms that beta blockers can call
throughout the body and we don't want
that to happen so let me show you how to
do pencil occlusion
so after insulin drops occupation close
the eye and then just take your finger
and you're going to hold it the bridge
of the nose where the punctum are and
you're going to hold firmly but gently
for two to three minutes and have the
patient just move their eye around to
coat their eye with the solution but
just keep those ducts occluded so that
is how you administer eyedrops thank you
so much for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for more videos